(dramatic music)
- Kiting does feel like flying
because sometimes we
actually do leave the ground
and actually fly through the air.
The feeling when you're
riding behind a snowkite
is unlike any other feeling in the world.
Just total freedom,
it's a combination of
feeling like you're flying
or gliding across the
ground with no resistance,
no effort and just a ton
of wind in your face.
My name is Tom Fredericks,
and I'm a snowkiter.
Snowkiting is basically getting pulled
on the snow with a giant kite.
To be able to snowkite,
you need a big 4-line kite,
a waist harness that you
hook into in your skis.
Twelve years ago, I moved to Alaska
to establish the first
kiteboarding and snowkiting school.
I fell in love with the
mountains and the open air.
Thompson Pass is one of
the best snowkiting venues
in the United States, if not the world.
Just because of the plentiful
snow, the wide open terrain
and the steep mountains.
It makes it truly a world class venue.
Alaska Kite Adventures puts on
the Snowkite Festival every year.
We have about 30 to 45
snowkiters come out to compete.
At the Snowkite Festival, we offer clinics,
races and competitions,
and also a community forum
for us to exchange ideas
and teach the public about snowkiting.
I think snowkiting is so unique as a sport
because it's been overlooked
for so many years.
It has a small group of
passionate followers.
The snowkite community
for me is so important
because it is a legacy
that I helped start.
And to go from seeing
like two or three people
when I first moved up here 12 years ago,
to about 200 people snowkiting in Alaska,
that's super important.
(cheers)